-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
let's get to the news.
Trump 2020 campaign lawyer
Jenna Ellis pleaded guilty today
to a criminal charge
in the Georgia election
interference case,
making her
former President Trump's
fourth codefendant of the trial
to plead guilty.
So I guess in the end,
he did teach them all
the art of the deal.
[ Laughter ]
That's right.
Jenna Ellis pleaded guilty
to a criminal charge
in the Georgia election case,
making her
Trump's fourth codefendant
of the trial to plead guilty.
You might remember
Ellis as the least weird lawyer
from this press conference.
[ Laughter ]
She's the one sticking out
like a normal thumb.
She looks like Marilyn
from "The Munsters."
For the kids.
Got to put one of those...
It's 2023?
[ Laughter ]
Michael Cohen is set to testify
today in a Manhattan courtroom
against former President Trump
in his civil fraud trial.
It's a big deal,
even though this picture
makes it look like
a "People's Court" case
about the property line
between two strip clubs.
[ Laughter ]
At his rally in New Hampshire
last night,
former President Trump
appeared to mistake
the leaders of
Hungary and Turkey.
You know, people come up to me
and they say,
"Oh, the Trump jokes
must write themselves."
And usually I say, "No,
it's hard to write Trump jokes."
But then the guy gets on stage
and confuses
Hungary with Turkey
and I got to go, "Okay, yeah...
today, they write themselves."
[ Laughter ]
Republicans have nominated
Minnesota Representative
Tom Emmer for
speaker of the House,
but it remains to be seen
whether Emmer
can get past these "effers."
[ Laughter ]
The House Freedom Caucus
yesterday
called on Republican lawmakers
to remain in Washington
until they're able to select
a new speaker.
Said Matt Gaetz, "Oh,
but I promised my girlfriend
we'd go trick or treating."
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
Texas Republic-- [ Chuckles ]
Texas Republican
Congressman Pete Sessions
said yesterday
that former President Trump
called him
about the speaker race
and said they had
a "polite conversation."
Um, eh, I hate to tell you,
but that wasn't him.
[ Laughter ]
Trump having
a polite conversation
would be the clue
in an action movie
so the hero would know
which one to shoot.
[ Laughter ]
Alabama Congressman
Gary Palmer announced
before today's
Republican conference meeting
that he has dropped out
of the race for speaker,
though I'm not sure
that merited an announcement.
That's like calling Wendy's
to cancel your reservation.
[ Laughter ]
A Kremlin spokesman today
dismissed longstanding rumors
that Russian President
Vladimir Putin uses body doubles
and said, "This evokes
nothing but a smile."
And then he tried so hard
to smile...
that a little pee came out.
[ Laughter ]
New York Mayor Eric Adams
announced yesterday
that another
16,000 city employees
will be permitted
to work from home.
Unfortunately,
they're all garbage collectors.
[ Laughter ]
The Justice Department yesterday
filed a civil forfeiture claim
for a superyacht
reportedly belonging
to a sanctioned
Russian billionaire.
"Hold up!
Let me disembark first,"
said Clarence Thomas.
[ Audience groans ]
According to a new report
from Uber Eats,
the most frequently
paired food and alcohol
were ribeye steak and vodka.
Who did you poll --
The cast of "Mad Men"?
[ Laughter ]
Even a death row prisoner
would say,
"I don't know,
that sounds kind of heavy."
And finally,
Pepsi over the weekend unveiled
a new diner experience
in New York
to celebrate
its 125th anniversary.
Because nothing captures
the diner experience
more than finding out
they only serve Pepsi.
And that was a monologue,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are off and running.
I've got a great show
for you tonight.
He is a Grammy-nominated
stand-up.
All of us here on the show
are big fans of his.
Shoemaker always
goes around saying
he's his favorite comedian,
even though I am right here.
[ Laughter ]
He's hosting "SNL" this weekend
with musical guests
Foo Fighters,
so he's right
in the thick of it.
I can't wait to talk to him.
Nate Bargatze is back
on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And he's one of our favorites.
He's back on Broadway
in "Gutenberg! The Musical!"
at the James Earl Jones Theatre.
He is one of the best
of all time.
Andrew Rannells
is going to be joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And she is a brilliant author.
She is a friend of this show.
She has a fantastic new novel,
"Let Us Descend."
It's out today.
Jesmyn Ward is back, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
During the old strike,
my brother and I
started a podcast.
That's us as children.
It's called "Family Trips
with the Meyers Brothers,"
and, boy oh boy, are we having
a grand old time doing it.
This week,
a new episode just dropped today
with our friend Jimmy Kimmel.
Right there,
there's Jimmy Kimmel.
We talked
to Millie Bobby Brown,
we talked to Leslie Jones.
Leslie Jones.
If you're -- If you're
in the car with your kids
and you want to listen
to a podcast
where you talk to celebrities
about the family trips
they took, don't listen
to the Leslie Jones one.
[ Laughter ]
Haim, though, that was clean.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Also, speaking of family
and speaking of home,
I'm going back to my home
state of New Hampshire.
I'm going to do a show
in Manchester, New Hampshire,
that's on November 4th.
It's a Saturday
at the SNHU Arena.
That's Southern New Hampshire
University Arena.
And you know what?
Shoemaker, you know
what it used to be called?
The Verizon Arena. So...
I was pretty --
I was I was pretty bummed out
when they changed the name.
[ Laughter ]
Moving on, everybody.
With 2024 just
around the corner,
the race for president
is beginning to take shape.
Which brings us
to a segment we call
"Race for the White House."
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
You know, there was a real fear
coming out
of the writers strike,
"Hey, are they going to skimp
on graphic packages now?"
[ Laughter ]
It was recently reported that
polling from New Hampshire
shows that Ron DeSantis
is currently in third place,
with double digit support.
This news is so good
for DeSantis,
it's enough to
make him weird smile.
[ Laughter ]
-Leave him alone!
-Excuse me?
Haven't we made fun
of Ron DeSantis enough?
-Yeah, well, you know,
it's just he's a public figure,
so I think it's okay
to make jokes about him.
-Leave him alone!
Poor guy.
He's just doing the best he can.
The last thing he needs
after a long day
of telling everybody
they're woke is to get home,
turn on the TV
and see you taking jabs at him.
Leave him alone!
-I'm sorry. Are you
a Ron DeSantis supporter?
-If I'm a supporter of anything,
it's kindness, compassion,
not mean-spirited jokes.
If you have to make fun
of somebody, make fun of me.
-Yeah, I just
don't even know you.
So why would I make fun of you?
-Well, you could make fun
of the fact
that I'm unable to pee
in public restrooms,
but I can only poop in crowds.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't want
to make fun of that.
I usually just tell jokes about
people who are in the news.
People like Ron DeSantis.
-Oh, sure,
make fun of Ron DeSantis.
Have your fun.
Go ahead and say he looks
like a handsome man
who's been stung
by a thousand bees.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
That's pretty harsh.
-I know, so leave him alone!
-I would like to get back
to my jokes, please.
-Oh, you want something
to joke about? How about this?
You could make fun
of the fact that
instead of having night terrors,
I have day terrors
where I startle myself asleep.
Aah!
-Sir! Wake up!
-[ Stammering ]
Oh, leave him alone!
[ Laughter ]
-I really don't want
to make fun of you.
-Are you sure?
Because you could
make fun of the fact
that my teeth
are as soft as chalk,
and my tongue is as hard
as a blackboard.
And sometimes when I eat,
I accidentally do math.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Don't you "wow" me.
I'm the last person you want to
get into a wowing contest with.
-A wowing contest?
-Yes.
In high school,
I was the state "wow" champion
three years running.
-That's not a thing.
-That's not a thing?
Wo-o-o-o-ow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes. Thank you.
-Just...
-You want something else
to joke about?
-No!
-Then how about this?
You could make fun of the fact
that my wife and I
have two kids.
-Why would I make fun of that?
-Well, the kids need to stay
on the farm
because our apartment
doesn't allow goats.
-[ Groans ]
-You see, baby goats
are called kids.
-Don't fist bump him!
[ Laughter ]
Sir, please,
just take your seat.
-Oh, well, where would you
like me to take it?
To a different talk show
where the host isn't mean?
-I'd be fine with that.
-Wo-o-o-ow-wow-wow-wow.
If you want something
to joke about, joke about this.
You can make fun of the fact
that I don't believe in tipping.
I think you should
always use a condom.
[ Laughter, audience groans ]
-Remember when you
all applauded his long "wow"?
-I also call it my long "wow."
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-Stick to the cards!
I --
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'd really...
I'd really like
to just continue my show.
-Fine. Get back to
your Ron DeSantis jokes.
But you know
what I'd say to that?
-Leave them alone?
-Leave them alone!
[ Cellphone ringing ]
Oh. Oop. Sorry about that.
My --
My kids are calling me.
They need to be
picked up from school.
[ Laughter ]
[ Imitating goat bleating ]
[ Coughs, clears throat ]
Sorry. I had something
in my throat.
I'll be there at three, kids.
-So that sentence is
a lot longer in goat?
-Yes.
-Get out of here!
-Okay, I'll go.
But remember, everyone:
♪ There's room to be kind
if you just use your mind ♪
♪ I must condone
you leave him alone ♪
Wink!